Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get into the Friday mailbag.
Anybody can be on the mailbag.
You simply have to write into info at David
Pakman dot com.
We have a whole bunch of different types of
emails that we get.
We get policy deep policy wonk type emails,
we get superficial criticisms, we get praise
and we also get trolling.
And today we're going to start with just a
little bit of trolling.
It's always good just to get a sense of the
types of things I get.
Peter wrote in and Peter says, You're a political
hack, empty vessel.
Are you ever going to take that war criminals
phallus out of your mouth?
And yours is why are you apostrophe free out
of you are mouth you pro imperialist progressive
boot licking peasant brain loser.
No wonder you have a for profit opinion show,
not a new non-for-profit newscast.
You don't do news, you preach one sided B.S.
What's very interesting is this is from a
left winger.
This is left wing hate mail.
They believe I am an imperialist and not really
a progressive, and that I just love Joe Biden.
The supposed imperial imperialist war criminal.
And that the fact that this is not a nonprofit
show is part of the problem.
Now, what's funny is he kind of agrees with
Alex Jones in a sense.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So, yes, my show, like basically every other
YouTube podcast show, is not a nonprofit.
A lot of people might not even realize they
have a nonprofit.
You need a board.
I mean, it's it's actually quite complicated
to be a nonprofit and it doesn't really make
sense for a whole bunch of different reasons.
We considered it at one point.
These are folks who are in the you can never
be progressive enough category.
And that's why I flagged this one.
We get a lot of right wing hate mail.
But the left wing hate mail is also interesting
because in theory, Peter is someone with whom
I probably agree 95% of the time, maybe even
98% of the time.
But this is exactly the type of stuff that
hurts the left.
And you really hate to see it, but I can't
control it.
It is what it is.
Vincent wrote in Vincent.
Now this is right wing hate.
Vincent is a very anti-Semitic.
Vincent says Pacman.
Why is the left woke crowd so dominated by
Jews?
Without Jews support, the left would die on
the vine.
Same is true for Wokeism only the financial
and intellectual support from Jews allows
wokeism and leftism to continue their evil
existence.
Why do most Jews support such evil?
Yikes.
So remember, you know, bunch of different
things.
Jewish Americans, much like black Americans,
are a very left wing voting bloc, one of the
most left wing voting blocs in the country.
When it comes to Wokeism as defined, I guess
by Vincent, it's a relatively small part of
what there is on the left.
I think it's extremely overrepresented in
social media and extremely overrepresented
by right wing media.
But sometimes when they say Wokeism, you know,
I've talked about where there can be excesses
sometimes on the left.
And I say, sure, I can talk about this, but
these aren't like huge deals on the left.
Sometimes what the right means by Wokeism
is we're against treating people terribly
because of their identity.
That's considered wokeism.
Earlier in the week, we had this clip of this
Republican mom saying, I don't like all this
Marxist stuff like anti-bullying.
Yeah, sometimes that's what they mean.
They're just really angry that it's not okay
to criticize people who don't look or sound
like you anymore.
So anyway, pathetic stuff, anti-Semitic stuff
for sure, but very, very common out there.
Oh, here's a nice, nice voicemail about my
recent interview with Adam Stein.
My compliments.
I was quite impressed with your interview
of Adam Stein of Wisconsin.
I really don't know how many interviewers
could keep such an even keel when faced with
some of the responses.
Adam had my compliments to you, sir.
I get this question a lot.
Like in my personal life as well.
How do you remain so cool with these people?
There's two parts of it.
One is just the experience of doing it.
The second part, sadly, is a little bit of
desensitization when you've heard this crazy
stuff for a decade and a half.
You do become somewhat desensitized to the
level of depravity that is exhibited by many
of these folks.
And I don't know that that's a particularly
good thing because I'm sort of suffering from
a normalization in a sense.
I'm still against the things they say.
But I'm used to hearing them when they are
very much not normal.
So something to think about.
Ryan wrote in about preventing life.
Also the notion from the Adam Steen interview
and Ryan says, Hey, David, the notion of preventing
life is completely absurd.
You're possibly preventing life with nearly
every action you take.
For example, I didn't get my morning coffee
today because I was running late.
Therefore, I didn't happen to run into my
future wife.
Therefore, we didn't go on to have children,
thereby preventing a life.
Any action can be seen as preventing a life.
Thanks, David Ryan from Milwaukee.
Yeah, it's sort of like a.
It's like a chaos theory on right wing brain
worms.
Adam Stein was saying not only is he against
birth control, I'm sorry, not only is he against
abortion, he's against birth control as well,
because you're preventing life.
Very, very weird argument, and it didn't make
it.
He even seemed confused by it, quite frankly.
Karl wrote in, Karl says, Are you streaming
any debates?
I'm in Pittsburgh and would love to see you
do a stream of Fetterman versus Oz or SHAPIRO
versus Mastriano.
Oh, and a silly name suggestion for the Financial
Show, Pacman, the financial fact man.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I have a whole bunch of different streams
that are scheduled.
When it comes to debates tonight, we've got
Abbott versus Beto.
Next week we have J.D.
Vance versus Tim Ryan, and then we have Mark
Kelly versus Blake Masters.
The week after that, we've got DeSantis versus
Crist, Whitmer versus Tudor Dixon.
And if it happens, the Raphael Warnock versus
Herschel Walker debate, although who the hell
knows whether any of those debates are going
to happen?
Week after that, we've got Rubio versus Val
Demings if it gets confirmed as versus Fetterman
and then the week after that, nothing's scheduled
yet.
So there's there's actually close to like
a dozen different debates that I plan on covering,
and I hope you'll join me for those.
Dan wrote in, David, Sir, why doesn't Fetterman
just take the Montreal Cognitive Assessment
Exam?
I would love to see Republicans make light
of the very exam Trump has been bragging about
for years.
Yeah, we had a voicemail call there last week
with a similar idea, which was basically Trump
took a dementia stroke brain injury test and
brags about it like it gets him into Mensa.
If Fetterman took it.
Who?
Fetterman had a stroke.
And now there's people saying, Oh, we can't
think.
Whatever.
If Fetterman took it and passed it, would
Republicans then be satisfied?
And the answer is, of course not.
They would all of a sudden say, it's not sufficient.
We it's I know that HANNITY and Trump and
everybody brags about this test like it's
the be all, end all of intelligence and cognition.
But if it was what Fetterman said and by the
way, I got an email from a neurologist in
our audience who said, you know, David, it's
not a what if?
Almost certainly Fetterman was given that
test, that assessment, because he had a stroke.
And it's typical that that's what you do.
It's not used for what Trump used it for.
It's stunning, stunning stuff.
Then a different Dan wrote in about our YouTube
thumbnails.
Now this I want to address in some serious
some depth.
Dan says those YouTube thumbnails that involve
a ridiculous facial expression.
Dude, please don't do that anymore.
Your content is remarkable and consistent
and on point.
You don't need that cringe kind of gimmickry.
Much loved Dan.
Listen guys, they're just YouTube thumbnails.
Okay, I get it.
There is things that there are trends on YouTube
and other platforms that are kind of gimmicky.
Sometimes they're even a little cringeworthy.
But one of the things we do is we adapt.
If we did, our titles today are dramatically
different than what they were a decade ago.
Okay, the conventions and what does well on
our different platforms change over time.
Titles have changed.
Our set has changed.
The audio equipment has changed.
How the show is produced has changed.
And yes, thumbnails change.
And sometimes we test thumbnails where I have
a goofy look on my face.
If that alone makes you not want to watch
or listen to the show anymore, then I'm sorry,
because really the content is what I would
hope would be most important.
But we're rolling with the changes.
If you don't adapt, you die in our space.
So listen, if those funny faces don't do well,
we'll stop using them.
If they go out of style, we'll stop using
them.
If they hurt us, we'll stop using them.
But we're just testing different things, that's
all.
All right.
Please, folks with peace and love, Barney
wrote in about something that is really, really
important.
Barney wrote to me and said, America is a
food desert.
David Englishmen traveling through the USA
here currently in Chicago.
I speak to a lot of Europeans on my travels
and we are shocked that much of the U.S. is
a food desert and that we are all completely
undernourished and cannot follow a typically
healthy diet we might adhere to.
In Europe, it's impossible to find cheap,
healthy food literally anywhere, writes Barney.
It costs $7 for a salad, $13 for a footlong
subway, for example.
I even found it's more expensive to buy Florida
oranges in Florida than it is for me to get
Spanish oranges in England.
Yes, I understand inflation's a factor, but
this is happening everywhere.
And despite this growth reason, groceries
and healthy foods in particular are obscenely
expensive.
I think the reason is you have one national
supermarket, so there's no competition and
there are a general lack of supermarkets compared
to the UK.
So this part, I don't know.
We have more than don't we have.
I mean, there's Trader Joe's, there's Whole
Foods.
There's.
Well, that's actually interesting is is Wegmans
National?
I'm not even sure.
Maybe Barney is on to something.
Maybe we only have, like, two national supermarket
chains.
Like, I know.
Stop and Shop is just a northeast thing, I
believe.
Yeah, that may be a problem.
Listen, Barney is completely correct, and
a lot of people, you know, when I've traveled
through the Midwest, small towns in the Northeast
typically have great food and plenty of supermarkets,
you know, upstate New York and Vermont and,
you know, Maine, these there's typically no
issue.
But when I've been in like Wisconsin, when
I've been in northern Indiana, when I've been
in even Kansas City, Missouri is like, okay,
right in the city.
But then it gets a little bit rough.
It is a major problem and there's multiple
problems.
There's the the pricing issue, of course,
the food desert issue where there are I mean,
even even in New York and Boston, there are
poorer neighborhoods with a dearth of options
other than chain restaurants.
And there's also a lack of education, sadly,
as to what constitutes a healthy diet.
What does it mean to eat a healthy diet?
Well, I don't know.
I eat I eat chicken and vegetables, but what
do you mean?
Well, yeah, I mean, it's wings that I fried
as well as, you know, mashed potatoes right
there, fries, whatever.
There are definitely misunderstandings about
how a diet should be established.
And honestly, part of the problem is that
that old school food pyramid also was somewhat
inaccurate and confusing.
So, Barney, you have correctly pointed out
that there's a lot of problems with food here
in the United States.
And it's really like trying to you kind of
like trying to dig yourself out.
But as you do it, you're digging another hole.
I don't know if it's the right metaphor.
Get your emails into me.
Info at David Pakman dot com.
Tell me your stories of food desserts probably
worthy of a clip coming up soon.
And we will see everybody on today's bonus
show, which you can sign up for at join Pacman
dotcom coupon code indict.
That's the coupon code.
Everybody knows why the coupon code is currently
indict.
We need some indictments.
The evidence is there.
It's time.
See you on the bonus show or otherwise.
Back here on Monday.